that's a big penis it is a big penis
[Music]
so today the try guys and their dads are
reacting to try guys videos we've talked
a little bit about you and who you are
but now we thought it'd be fun to talk
about me talking about you is something
you do very well why are you why would
you wear this on camera dad because I
want him to give me all of the new ones
what do you not like it when I do in
videos the one where we were like
wearing giant dick costumes yeah kind of
done my bow on that one you have to pay
stains all over it you know what's your
favorite try guys video you've seen
I like the educational ones I guess that
you could say they're all educational
yeah I like to think that I just don't
all educate you on things you need to
know let's watch some of these videos so
the first video is the try guys labor
pain simulator hmm do you think it's
funny yeah yeah you like seeing me and
Ron it's tough to watch Ned in pain Zak
I would you ever do something like this
show me your date I see no reason to do
anything like this no I I think it's
good to see someone else it's good
enough for me but today you're getting
paid for it if nothing else I'm
screaming hard there why am i watching
this this is just stupid and you don't
even get a baby out of it
no I put in here my balls it's really
painful yeah why did you do that because
that's where my vagina would be oh I
said aren't you proud of me you don't
have to answer that
oh the try guys drag perform it's great
one you became a star in this how do I
look
oh that's you please you're so so
outstanding sexy
yuvigi looks sexy yeah isn't hot do you
think was the hottest okay not Keith
he's gorgeous she's sexy but she's also
a little dirty you have to be have you
ever tried walking in heels
absolutely not not even like for funsies
not but no it's like a nice limb when a
drag queen looks like a real woman they
call them a fish I'm say he's fishy who
do you think is the best-looking try guy
I'm closer you didn't end thank you I
would rather ugly
nevermind you do new t-shirt we move on
to the try guys ancient Olympics do you
think it's bad that I'm naked so much on
camera well really no you got a nice
smile you smell a new tutorial thanks
dad so this is actually a half manure
half dirt so we were essentially rolling
around in poop it's better than peat
moss it stick to you the guess is better
be modest we spent uh more hours
pixelating this video than we spent
editing anything else we've ever done
it's like 40 hours blurring you'll see
how much is pixelated you know dick size
reference um oh damn dude in English I
really wanted to win I got that you've
had a history of getting intense for a
competition but that's actually why your
computer what are you doing you're
competing that's what you did what you
do that's what you do can you beat Zack
and Keith I think so next Oh try guys
Halloween costumes
this video is stupid this is stupid
you look adorable as a bug thank you
would you wear the bug I never give it
much thought
yeah yeah my dad hates this you seen a
vagina in that baby huge he has a vagina
in one of your iconic moments sure so
Zach was really excited that he his face
is the clitoris oh that's too high
oh my God we're all proud of him and he
who need to dress up in a penis costume
that's our Ned so I have a history of
not liking giantic does that mean that
you have a history of not liking big
dicks weight College I collided with a
person in Peters costume because I was
just trying to tackle him and I got a
black eye you got a black eye from a
giant dick yeah oh my god all right so
this is try guys try prostate exams you
are a doctor did you particularly like
this video I thought it was it was a
good educational video do you do that a
lot you have to do that to blah blah you
have to K do it to yourself you have to
be very flexible
hmm so we've been going to the UCLA
Medical Center for all our medical
videos they've got to know us real well
I'll bet yeah do you think I'm ever
gonna regret having a prostate exam on
camera no when you show your kids I'm
certain that these videos are effecting
change if this video helps one person
it's worth it I'm sure it helped a lot
more than one see we're getting fingers
up our butts for a reason um alright
let's swim with sharks which try guy was
least comfortable with this we all
thought it was gonna be Zach
cuz acts afraid of fish just like normal
fish I have witnessed it many times but
Ned you freaked out you had a really
tough time that's a real sharks right
yeah they're not fake shark huh it's not
CGI oh but it was scary would you ever
do this no way yeah let's make that
clear many other things that you do on
video I would never do what would happen
if I got my arm bitten off well you have
to call EMS and then call the lawyer
later yeah yeah for sure is the try guys
fertility test
aka the sperm jackoff race do you ever
think the things we do in videos are
embarrassments to our family I don't
think of it family terms I guess I'm
just embarrassing myself you're on your
own this one Zach took 40 minutes well
he want to make sure it was done well he
kept missing the car he did this and
he'd miss he was too excited you have
any questions for me hi we better leave
that one alone this is try guys try
stripping this would be fun Wow nice mug
yeah that's our it's your future
daughter-in-law what Zach's dancing on
her she had a great time oh you're
probably trying to get feedback or
something that week what is then
it's his body hair Oh luck to behind
Zach I'm proud of your net thanks dad
good job
I don't know you've been serious turn hi
everyone looks like she's having the
time of her life there okay Weimer I
mean looks like do you think that was
inappropriate to me do you think you
would let Eugene dance on mom
absolutely not yeah good tense for you
thank you should I switch jobs now you
may be Musa job of all the strippers who
did you think was the best each one was
unique don't whine it was better than
the others okay some of those categories
I don't normally try to evaluate every
other death at 7% was the best and my
dad refused so uh that was all the video
clips
thanks for coming and doing all these
videos with us and watching all these
videos I'm sure that wasn't easy for you
know I wasn't what do you think of our
stuff I think it's great you're not
you're not fazed at all no I love them I
love laughing I love getting to know you
guys you know I feel like a guys are
like part of my life so you're not
embarrassed at all no no I didn't want
em but uh since in my life I still live
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching try your eyes
thank you for having me it was fun time
using you want me to buy your new shirt
right right okay